Hi all, and welcome to the RCA Q&
A application Pot demo,
a tool designed to reimagine how we
interact with our data.
At its core,
the tool introduces a straightforward
chat interface designed to turn static,
intricate data sets into interactive,
conversational insights.
Users can ask questions in a natural
language and receive either direct
answers or detailed analytical insights
instantly.
This empowers decision making by allowing
users to talk to their data,
receiving both visual and contextual
responses that drive faster,
more informed strategies.
By merging advanced AI with an intuitive
chat based UI,
this solution bridges the gap between
overwhelming datasets and actionable
business intelligence.
Now let's see the tool in action.
The tool is now able to generate answers
as well as visualizations based on the
question asked.
Thank you for exploring the RCA Q&
A application POT demo and have a nice
day.